if you want customers to refer business
to you you have to over-deliver like
crazy because your customers are busy
people just like you are and you are not
on top of their mind if you do not over
deliver like crazy they're going to
forget about you hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today maintain a
question from one of my newsletter
readers Christian who are insane hi Evan
I said that the business your newsletter
has really assisted me great to hear
thanks Christian I want rapid growth
awesome I find it difficult to penetrate
my customers and get more referrals how
do I solve this Christian you have to
give them a better experience you have
to over-deliver like crazy so they can't
help but talk about you and it's not
good enough to just be good you know I
believe that whatever you're selling is
good I'm assuming that okay if you're
selling something crappy then you got to
gather business and do something else
I'm assuming you're good at what you do
and you're selling a quality product but
that's not enough you have to
over-deliver you have to wow them your
customers are busy people they have a
million things going on in their lives
just like you do so you have to think
about something that's going to break
through all that clutter and really make
them say wow Christian really is amazing
give them a story that they can't help
go and tell their friends about here's a
quick example I'm an investor in a dance
company here in Toronto will teach five
to six thousand people a year how to
dance salsa it's a lot of fun anyway
coming to Toronto dance sauce that's the
name of the company if you take a class
you're not just signing up for a dance
class it's an experience and that's why
it's become one of the largest dance
schools may be the largest for salsa in
North America when you come to class
you're going to get an amazing class
you're going to get the best class
you've ever signed up for for dancing
we're going to make you feel comfortable
you're going to have fun you're going to
get the moves you're going to release
your stress you're going to feel active
you're going to love it but that's not
enough we don't just offer great classes
will help you with music that you can
dance to we'll help you find your shoe
will help answer any questions you have
we'll give you guidance will have
socials will have outings to help you
come out in practice we have our
advanced students come out and help out
and assist in the classes to give you
advice and feedback as well as
instructors who walk around you become
part of the family signing up for a
class with Toronto dance salsa becomes
an experience you're not just taking a
salsa class and people love it and they
can't help but go home and tell their
friends about it and tell their families
about and say you should sign up for
this class we don't have to do a lot of
aggressive marketing we don't have to
convince people or do a sales pitch
because our customers are the best
source of referrals and traffic for you
and that's what you want right
entrepreneurs we don't have huge budgets
if you got a million dollars to go out
and spend on advertising and go ahead
but for everybody else you need your
customers to talk about you spread the
word and for them to do that you have to
give them a reason and it comes from
over delivering like crazy on the
service wow them with your service and
they'll tell your story for you and
they'll bring people to your company
whatever dollars you're going to put
into your marketing put it into the
service experience you have to be weight
above better and different than your
closest competition that will make you
stand out that'll get people talking
about you good luck question for those
of you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I love
seeing those come in and hey if you have
a question about this video or comment
or question about your own business I'd
love to hear from you I always check
those comments every morning when I'm
eating my breakfast I love a scene they
come in so please leave a comment below
thank you guys so much and I'll see you
on the next episode
you